how do fears within a character raise
the stakes
fears are everything fears are also
something that we all have and when you
look at what is the character's dream
versus what is their biggest fear when
we look at the biggest fear we're
looking at the consequence in the idea
of how the internal Stakes are affecting
the character and how they make Choice
there are many writers that don't
set up the fear and when you fail to set
up the fear then you fail to set up the
internal and or external Stakes at a
level where the audience identifies
again I fear is something very Universal
in all of us I always say to writers
what is the worst thing that can happen
if the goal is not achieved
and that goes into fear
can we explore incorporating the past
present and future into story yes
the past is the earlier wound and when
you're looking at the past it can be an
event like in uh in the show the split
when you have the the inciting incident
be a father who returns after a 30-year
absence then you are in immediate
recognition
of the Void
in the familial members because of this
choice so the past in that situation is
defined by an event versus uh the past
you can also
identify by uh someone who's just
emotionally absent you can have a parent
who is an alcoholic and there is no
specific event but there is a wound that
happens from
the emotionally unavailable parent so
that goes into the past and then you the
present is something happens which
creates the why now that we are entering
the story when we are with the inciting
incident that splits open the earlier
wound and that something that happens is
awakens what happened earlier in life
and that with that Awakening the
character is
Loosely aware but through the pursuit
they become more aware of the earlier
wound I've seen structures that work
incredibly well when you have the
earlier wound when we feel how the
inciting incident awakens that wound
then we understand the void and when we
understand the void that again goes into
creating empathy and rooting interest uh
with the character then with the future
you are looking at will the character
transform or won't they transform did
you create the right external plot
for the character to become aware of
what was holding them back and is the
character in The mindset that they want
to heal and you have characters that we
feel the full transformation and you
have characters that you are left with
that you feel like they didn't learn and
there's value in both because in the
world there are people in both mindsets
staying within the Arc of growth
what's quieting the mind of the sort of
the the noisy survival mindset I like
that term yes
I have come into the recognition the
mindset thing was a new thing for me in
looking at character and character
Dynamics and recognizing that in life we
are in the intellectual mind we are in
the survival mind are we are in the
intuitive mind and for the majority of
our lives and we are very often rotating
from one mindset to the other for the
majority depending on the life phase and
where you're entering with the character
of Our Lives we are in survival mindset
so being in the survival mindset there's
more to play with with the flaws with
the vulnerability and think about how do
you move the character into the
intuitive mindset how what can happen to
the character that creates the Arc of
growth that moves them into the
intuitive mindset another parallel that
I often think about like when you think
in life how we are all brought up on the
idea of codependency and the I wherever
there's hierarchy which there is in the
family unit from the time we're born and
then we go into the work world and we go
into the Scholastic world and there is a
hierarchy and hierarchy creates
codependency and the the job for people
is to figure out how do you go from
codependency to interdependency and the
the value and I think it used to feel
like independency was the key to
everything but then the recognition was
interdependency so when you're looking
at how do you move from the mind
mindsets it's a similar thing that all
has to do with The Arc of growth of the
character
how could we show a codependent
character versus an interdependent
character versus an independent
character
so the codependent character is often a
character with an alcoholic parent
uh someone where the one of the parents
has been absent so there is a need that
is so connected with the comfort of
another person where they cannot
distinguish the difference in in the
value of the codependent character
person is the untransformed place in a
person's life or a character's life so
it gives you somewhere to go the
independent person can also be looked at
as a character that has a weakness or a
flaw if they're too independent that
that is creating an isolation in a
different way an independent person can
also be looked at as a plus
uh in that they're not dependent on
other people and then the interdependent
person character is the transformed
character who has gone through the
emotional work of what transpires in the
story through the actions obstacles
stake sequence
that leads them to a transformed state
so you can go from a character who is
flawed and codependent and have a
Pursuit that allows them an opportunity
to change and then at the climax they
become aware of the flaw and the choices
in becoming aware of the flaw are they
going to make a conscious Choice when it
comes to the resolution or are they
going to stay in the flawed thinking
so if I were to put labels and these are
my labels uh on a codependent character
needy in independent character selfish
and intra or interdependent would be
more balanced yes perfectly put okay so
that's how I could show these sort of
phases that are yeah interesting and it
all has to do with There's an
opportunity for growth and codependency
like a flaw is something that is in our
lives all the time because of the
hierarchy of and the interesting thing
for me I it wasn't until I went through
a divorce and someone said have you ever
looked at codependency and my immediate
reaction was I'm not codependent maybe
he was codependent and then I I read a
book on I think it was called
codependency no more and and it
described codependency as needing
someone to need you and I was like I'm
codependent how Wild so I understand the
transformation because I've gone through
it I've done the work to understand how
do I go from uh the feeling of the
hierarchy through the system that
Society sets up and then starting my own
business
and not having the agenda of others is
part of the outcome only having the
agenda of how do we get the story to the
best place possible all of that
emotional work is part of what led to my
transformation
and and just like in life roles can
change someone can be codependent and
then be the one that's sort of sought
after by the codependent yes our
characters can change too I mean maybe
they're codependent in one realm but
then they're actually the ones being
sought after by a codependent another
you know yes so and there's value like
the co-dependent person is certainly not
an a bad person it's not it it's 98 I
think it was the stat or 90 a society is
set up on codependency so part of our
life process and challenge in life
having to do with mindset is how do we
move from this survival mindset of
needing someone to need you into the
mindset that you are enough the flawed
thinking the negative narrative I'm not
enough I'm not lovable I'm you know I
don't deserve curve and how does the
story transform that thinking and bring
you to the idea of interdependency and
the idea of transformation
sure some of our most lovable characters
and you could say Bridget Jones is
probably very yes
exactly exactly and White Lotus
example yes yes very strong but then she
can flip on you and and and start yeah
so so she's real interesting I'm not
sure what her you know what they would
put in the DSM whatever it is five now
or whatever the book is but what her
classic case would be but some very
interesting stories have all been built
around a codependent character oh
exactly because you think about what
happens to a character when they lose
their comfort blanket which is a person
what happens to them which we all do in
life we lose we move on from from you
know being in the family unit to going
to college to the idea of moving away
from and as I always remember this
saying which I loved that that kind of
framed the idea when I was at spelling
television we did a show called uh Queen
Supreme and there was a quote that one
writer used in an episode that we spend
the first half of our Lives running away
from home and the second half trying to
get back
it's great isn't it